كتل من الرماد المكسورة والمعادن الملتوية،
كل ما تبقى من مبنى سكني كان
يسكنه أكثر من 40 شخصًا
بعد ظهر يوم السبت. وجاءت مكالمة من
شخص عرف نفسه على أنه رامي من
الجيش الإسرائيلي، وغادر المبنى
الآن سنتقيأ، فقال لحسن
لا تفعل ذلك.  قصف المبنى بأكمله،
دافع حسن عن ضرب شقة
الشخص المذنب، حيث يوجد أشخاص معوقون
هنا
بمجرد أن أصبح المبنى فارغًا، تم
قصفه
ولم يُقتل أو يُجرح أحد، لقد تم
التواصل معي للتعليق،
ولم يدخل الجيش الإسرائيلي في التفاصيل فحسب، بل ادعى فقط  لقد
ضربوا مراكز القيادة والسيطرة التي
تستخدمها حركة الجهاد الإسلامي للتخطيط
لأنشطة إرهابية ضد إسرائيل،
وأصر سكان المبنى على أنهم لا
يعرفون من هو الهدف
ومن قد يكون، وهذه هي
النتيجة التي
تركها عشرات الأشخاص دون سقف
فوق رؤوسهم.
مع انتهاكات متفرقة لوقف إطلاق النار،
عاد توم في الوقت الحالي،
أسواق غزة مفتوحة مرة أخرى
لأكثر من 2 مليون نسمة
محاصرين في هذا الشريط الضيق من الأرض،
ليس هناك توقع لسلام دائم،
مسلم يبلغ من العمر 56 عامًا، عاش جزارًا
في جميع ويلات غزة
الصراع الذي يقول إنه سيستمر حتى
يوم القيامة،
كفاح الذراع ليس هو الأولوية بالنسبة
لمعظم الناس هنا، لقد سئموا منه تلاشى الله
[موسيقى] وهم
يحاولون إيجاد
طريقهم عبر هذه الدوامة التي لا تنتهي من
العنف المتقطع.
بن ويتمان سي إن إن غزة
جيد